Me gustaría hacer casi lo mismo que hice la primera vez,
que es escoger un tema liviano.
La última vez hablé sobre la muerte y morir.
Esta vez voy a hablar de enfermedades mentales.
Pero esto tiene que tener algo de tecnología,
Así que les voy a hablar de la terapia de electroshock. (Risas)
Ustedes saben, desde que el hombre tiene noción
que algunos de sus pares, sus colegas,
podían ser diferentes, podrían ser extraños, podían estar severamente deprimidos
o lo que ahora reconocemos como esquizofrenia...
El hombre tenía la certeza de que este tipo de enfermedad
tenía que provenir de espíritus malignos ingresando al organismo.
La manera, entonces, de tratar estas enfermedades
al principio era, de una u otra manera,
exorcizar esos espíritus malignos. Y esto sigue sucediendo, como saben.
Pero no era suficiente usar a los sacerdotes.
Cuando la medicina se volvió medianamente científica, alrededor del 450 A.C.,
con Hipócrates y esos chicos,
buscaban hierbas, plantas,
que, literalmente, remecerían a los malos espíritus para sacarlos.
Entonces, encontraron ciertas plantas que podían causar convulsiones.
Y los "Herbarios", los libros de botánica de la Edad Media,
del Renacimiento, están llenas de recetas
para causar convulsiones para remecer a los malos espíritus hasta sacarlos.
Finalmente, alrededor del siglo 16,
un médico llamado Theophrastus Bombastus Auricularis von Hohenheim,
más conocido como Parcelso, un nombre que puede ser familiar para algunos de los que están aquí
(Risas) el bueno de Paracelso...
Descubrió que se podía predecir el grado de convulsión
usando una cantidad medida de canfor para producir la convulsión.
¿Se imaginan meterse al armario, sacar una bola de polillas y masticarla
si se sintieran deprimido?
Es mejor que el Prozac, pero no lo recomendaría.
Entonces, lo que vemos en el siglo 17, 18
es la búsqueda continua de medicamentos más alla del canfor que hicieran el truco.
Bueno, ahí aparece Benjamin Franklin,
¡y casi se provoca convulsiones a sí mismo!
Con un rayo de electricidad al final de su cometa.
Y entonces la gente empezó a pensar en electricidad para producir convulsiones.
Después, avanzamos hasta alrededor de 1932,
cuando tres psiquiatras italianos, que trataban ampliamente la depresión,
empezaron a notar entre sus pacientes que además eran epilépticos,
que si tenìan un ataque... una serie de ataques epilépticos,
muchos seguidos... la depresión muy frecuentemente disminuiría.
Y no sólo disminuiría, pero quizás no volvería más.
Entonces se interesaron mucho en producir convulsiones,
midieron tipos de convulsiones.
Y entonces pensaron: "bueno, tenemos electricidad, enchufaremos a alguien la toma de corriente".
"Eso siempre hace que el pelo se pare y que la gente convulsione".
Así que, lo intentaron en algunos puercos, y ninguno se murió.
Entonces, fueron a la policía y dijeron:
"Sabemos que en la estación de trenes
están todas estas almas perdidas deambulando,
hablando sinsentidos. Nos pueden traer a alguno?
Alguien que está, como dicen los italianos, "cagutis".
Así que encontraron a un "cagutis",
un hombre de 39 años que era un esquizofrénico sin esperanzas,
se sabía, desde hace meses,
que, literalmente, se defecaba solo,
hablaba sólo sinsentidos.
Y lo llevaron al hospital.
Entonces, estos tres psiquiatras, después de dos o tres semanas de observación,
lo acostaron en una mesa,
le conectaron una cantidad muy baja de corriente en la sien.
Pensaron: "bueno, tratemos 55 volts, dos décimas de segundo".
"No le va a hacer nada terrible".
Y lo hicieron.
Bueno, yo obtuve lo siguiente de un observador de primera mano,
que me dijo esto como 35 años atrás,
cuando estaba pensando sobre estos temas
para un proyecto de investigación...
me dijo: "Este tipo -- recuerden, ni siquieran lo pusieron a dormir --
"después de esta gran convulsión,
se sentó, miró a los tres tipos que estaban ahí y dijo:
"¿Qué mierda están tratando de hacer, maricones?"
(Risas)
Si sólo pudiera decir eso en italiano.
Bueno, ellos no podían estar más felices, porque
no había dicho ninguna frase cuerda durante las semanas de observación.
Así que lo enchufaron de nuevo
y esta vez usaron 110 volts por medio segundo.
Y para su asombro, después que se terminó,
empezó a hablar como si estuviera perfectamente bien.
Tuvo algunas recaídas, le dieron una serie de tratamientos
y, escencialmente, se curó.
Pero, claro, teniendo esquizofrenia,
dentro de unos meses, volvió.
Pero escribieron un paper sobre esto
y todo el mundo de occidente empezó a usar electricidad
para convulsionar personas que tenían esquizofrenia o estaban severamente deprimidas.
No funcionó muy bien con los esquizofrenicos,
Pero estaba bastante claro en los 30's y la mitada de los 40's
que la terapia electroconvulsica era muy, muy efectiva
en el tratamiento de la depresión.
Y, por supuesto, en esos días, no existían los fármacos antidepresivos
y se volvió muy, muy popular.
Se anestesiaba a la gente,
se le convulsionaba, pero la verdadera dificultad era
que no había manera de paralizar los musculos.
Entonces las personas tenían realmente grandes ataques.
Los huesos se les quebraban... especialmente con la gente vieja y frágil,
no podías usarlo.
Entonces, en los 1950's, al final de los 1950's, los llamados relajantes musculares
fueron desarrollados por farmacólogos
y llegó hasta un punto en que se podía inducir una convulsión completa,
una convulsión electroencefalográfica... se podía ver en las ondas cerebrales...
sin causar ninguna convulsión en el cuerpo, excepto un poco en los dedos de los pies.
Entonces, nuevamente, se volvió muy, muy popular y muy, muy útil.
Bueno, ya saben, en la mitad de los 60's
salieron los primeros antidepresivos. Tofranil fue el primero.
A fines de los 70's, principios de los 80's hubo otros
y eran muy efectivos.
Y los grupos defensores de los derechos del paciente parecieron preocuparse mucho
sobre el tipo de cosas que iban a presenciar.
Y toda la idea de terapia electroconvulsiva, electroshock, desapareció...
pero ha tenido un renacimiento en los últimos 10 años.
Y el motivo por el que tuvo un renacimiento
probablemente, es que alrededor del 10% de esa gente, depresivos severos,
no responden, independiente de lo que se les haga.
Ahora, ¿por qué les cuento esta historia en esta conferencia?
Les cuento esta historia porque de hecho desde que
Richard me llamó y me pidió que hablara
(al igual que le pidió a todos los expositores)
que hablara de algo que fuera nuevo para esta audiencia,
de lo que nunca antes habíamos hablado, ni escrito,
he estado planeando este momento.
la razón es en realidad porque yo soy un hombre al que hace casi 30 años atrás
le salvaron la vida con dos largas sesiones de electroshock.
Déjenme contarles esta historia.
Estaba, en los 1960's, en un matrimonio... usar la palabra "malo"
sería, quizás, la subestimación del año.
Era terrible.
Hay, estoy seguro, suficiente gente divorciada en esta sala
que saben sobre la hostilidad, la ira, que saben lo que es.
Siendo yo alguien que tuvo una infancia muy difícil,
una adolescencia muy difícil...
tuvo que ver... no precisamente con pobreza, pero bastante cerca.
Tenía que ver con haber sido críado en una familia donde nadie hablaba inglés,
nadie leía ni escribía en inglés.
Tenía que ver con muerte y enfermedad y muchas otras cosas...
tenía alguna tendencia a la depresión...
Entonces, en la medida que las cosas empeoraron, en la medida en que realmente nos empezamos a odiar,
me fui deprimiendo cada vez más en un período de un par de años,
tratando de salvar este matrimonio,
que inevitablemente no podía ser salvado.
Finalmente, programaba todos mis casos de cirujía importantes...
los programaba para las 12 o una de la tarde
porque no podía salir de la cama antes de las 11
Y cualquiera que ha estado deprimido acá sabe lo que es eso.
Ni siquiera podía quitarme las sábanas de encima.
Bueno, uno está en el centro médico universitario,
donde todos se conoces y esto está perfectamente claro para mis colegas
así que mis referencias empezaron a bajar.
En la medida en que mis referencias empezaron a bajar,
claramente me fui deprimiendo más y más rápido,
hasta que pensé, Dios, no puedo trabajar más.
Y, de hecho, no hacía ninguna diferencia
porque ya no tenía pacientes.
Así que, con el consejo de mi médico,
me interné en la unidad de Cuidado Psiquiátrico Agudo de nuestro hospital universitario.
Y mis colegas, que me conocían desde la escuela de medicina
en ese sitio dijeron: "no te preocupes, chap. En seis semanas"
"estás de vuelta en el quirófano. Todo estará magnífico".
Bueno, ¿saben lo que es excremento bovino?
Eso demostró ser bastante excremento bovino.
Conozco gente que se quedó para siempre en ese sitio con mentiras como esa.
(Risas)
Asi que yo era uno de sus fracasos.
Pero no era tan simple. Porque cuando
me salí de la unidad, estaba completamente disfuncional.
Apenas podías ver a cinco pies de distancia.
Me tropezaba al caminar. Andaba encorvado.
Rara vez me bañaba. A veces no me afeitaba. Era terrible.
Y era claro... no para mí,
porque nada era claro para mí en ese entonces...
que iba a necesitar hospitalización de larga duración
en ese terrible lugar llamado manicomio.
Así que me admitieron, en 1973, en la primavera de 1973,
al Institute of Living, que se llamaba antes Hartford Retreat.
Se fundó en el siglo 18,
es el hospital psiquiátrico más grande del estado de
Connecticut además de los grandes hospitales públicos
que existían en esa época.
Y trataron con todo lo que tenían.
Trataron la psicoterapia habitual.
Trataron todos los medicamentos disponibles en ese entonces.
Y sí tenían Tofranil y otras cosas... Mellaril, quién sabe qué.
No pasó nada, excepto que me dio ictericia producto de una de estas cosas.
Y finalmente, porque yo era bien conocido en Connecticut,
decidieron que lo mejor era tener una reunión con la gente importante.
Toda la plana mayor se reunió y, posteriormente, yo me enteré de qué había pasado.
Juntaron sus cabezas y decidieron
que no había nada que se pudiera hacer
por este cirujano que, esencialmente, se había separado del mundo.
Quien, para ese entonces estaba tan abrumado
...no sólo con su depresión y sentimiento
de invalidez y desadaptación,
sino que también con pensamiento obsesivo,
pensamiento obsesivo sobre coincidencias.
Y había números particulares que cada vez que veía
me ponían horriblemente angustiado, todo tipo de conductas rituales...
cosas, simplemente terribles.
¿Se acuerdan cuando eran niños y tenían que pisar todas las líneas?
Bueno, yo era un hombre grande que tenía todo este tipo de rituales.
Y llegó a un punto que había un incesante... un miedo feroz en mi cabeza.
Ustedes han visto el cuadro de Edvard Munch,
"El grtio". "El Grito". Cada momento era un grito.
Era imposible. Así que decidieron que no había terapia,
no había tratamiento. Pero había un tratamiento
en la que el hospital Hartford, a comienzo de los 1940's, había sido pionero.
Y se pueden imaginar qué era. Era la lobotomía prefrontal.
Así que decidieron... nuevamente, yo no sabía esto,
me enteré después...
que lo único que se podía hacer
para este hombre de 43 años era tener una lobotomía
prefrontal.
Bueno, como en todos los hospitales, había un residente
que tenía mi caso. Tenía 27 años
y nos juntábamos dos o tres veces a la semana.
Por supuesto, ya llevaba ahí... qué, tres o cuatro meses en ese entonces.
Y me pidió que me reuniera con la plana mayor y ellos aceptaron reunirse conmigo
porque él era muy bien considerado en ese lugar.
Ellos pensaban que él tenía un futuro extraordinario.
Él se puso firme y dijo:
"No. Conoco mejor a este hombre que cualquiera de ustedes. He estado con él una y otra vez.
Ustedes sólo lo ven a veces. Han leído reportes y esas cosas.
En realidad, honestamente, creo que el problema basico acá es depresión pura.
Y todo el pensamiento obsesivo viene de ahí.
Y ya saben, por supuesto, qué pasará si le hacen una lobotomía prefrontal.
Cualquier resultado del espectro,
desde muy mal a terrible, terrible, terrible,
va a suceder. Si hace su mejor esfuerzo,
no habrá más obsesiones,
probablemente no habrá depresión, pero sus afectos se anularán,
no volverá a operar jamás,
no volverá a ser el padre cariñoso que era para sus dos hijos,
su vida cambiará. Si tiene el resultado típico,
terminará como el de la película "One Flew Over the Cuckoo's Nest".
Y ustedes saben de eso, esencialmente estará dopado el resto de su vida".
"Bueno", dijo, "¿Por qué no probamos un tratamiento de electroshock?"
¿Y saben por qué estuvieron de acuerdo? Estuvieron de acuerdo para darle el gusto.
Simplemente pensaron: "bueno, le daremos una serie de 10.
Y perderemos algo de tiempo. Gran cosa. No hará ninguna diferencia".
Así que hicieron la serie de 10
y el primero... el tratamiento típico, incidentalmente, era de seis a ocho
y todavía es de seis a ocho...
me enchufaron los cables, me hicieron dormir, me dieron los relajantes musculares.
Seis no resultaron. Siete no resultaron.
Ocho no resultaron. Al noveno, noté...
y es maravilloso que pudiera notar algo
...noté un cambio. Al 10, noté un cambio real.
El volvió a hablar con ello y acordaron hacer otros 10.
De nuevo, ninguno de ellos
-creo que había siete u ocho de ellos-
creyó que esto serviría de algo. Pensaron que era un cambio temporal.
Pero, cielos, al 16 y 18,
había diferencias demostrables en cómo me sentía.
Al 18 y 19, dormía por las noches.
Al 20 tuve la sensación, la sensación real
de que podía superar esto,
que era suficientemente fuerte como para que, por un acto de voluntad,
podía hacer desaparecer el pensamiento obsesivo.
Podía sacarme la depresión de encima.
Y nunca me he olvidado... nunca me olvidaré
...de estar parado en la cocina de la unidad,
era una mañan de domingo en enero de 1973... 4...
parado en la cocina sólo y pensando: "tengo fuerzas para hacer esto".
Era como si eso cables enrollados apretadamente en mi cabeza se hubieran desconectado
y podía pensar con claridad.
Pero necesitaba una formula. Necesitaba algo para decirme a mí mismo
cuando empezara a pensar obsesivamente, con obsesiones.
Bueno, los fanáticos de Gilbert & Sullivan en esta sala
se acordarán de "Ruddy Gore" y se acordarán de la loca Margaret
y recordarán que estaba casada
con un sujeto de nombre Sir Despard Murgatroyd.
Y ella se volvía loca cada cinco minutos o algo así en la obra,
y se decía a sí misma: "debemos tener una palabra para traerla de vuelta a la realidad
y la palabra, cariño, será 'Basingstoke'".
Así que, cada vez que ella se volvía algo loca,
él díría: "¡Basingstoke!". Y ella diría:
"es Basingstoke". Y se mejoraría por un momento.
Bueno, yo vengo del Bronx, saben. No puedo decir "Basingstoke".
Pero tenía algo mejor. Y era muy simple.
Era: "¡Aah, a la mierda!"
(Risas). Mucho mejor que Basingstoke,
para mí, al menos. Y funcionaba, por Dios, funcionaba.
Cada vez que empezaba a pensar obsesivamente...
de nuevo, otra vez, después de 20 tratamientos de shock...
decía: "¡Aah, a la mierda!"
Y las cosas mejoraban y mejoraban.
Y dentor de tres o cuatro meses,
me dieron el alta de ese hospital y me uní a un grupo de cirujanos
donde podía trabajar con otras personas de la comunidad,
no en New Haven, pero bastante cerca.
Me quedé ahí por tres años.
Al terminar los tres años, volví a New Haven,
he permanecido ahí todo este tiempo.
Traje a mi esposa conmigo, en realidad, para asegurarme de que podía llevar esto a cabo.
Mis hijos volvieron a vivir con nosotros.
Tuvimos dos hijos más después de eso.
Resucité la carrera, incluso mejor de lo que había estado antes.
Volví a la universidad
y empecé a escribir libros.
Bueno, saben, ha sido una vida maravillosa.
Ha sido, como dije, cerca de 30 años.
Dejé de hacer cirugía hace como seis años atrás
y me convertí en un escritor a tiempo completo, como muchos saben.
Pero ha sido muy interesante. Ha sido muy feliz.
Cada cierto tiempo tengo que decir: "¡Aah, a la mierda!"
Cada cierto tiempo me deprimo de alguna manera y me pongo un poco obsesivo.
Así que no estoy libre de todo esto. Pero ha funcionado. Siempre ha funcionado.
¿Por qué he escogido, tras no haber hablado nunca sobre esto, hablar de esto ahora?
Bueno, para los que conocen algunos de estos libros
saben que uno es sobre la muerte y morir,
uno es sobre el cuerpo humano y el espíritu humano,
no es sobre la manera en que los pensamientos místicos están constantemente en nuestras mentes
y siempre han tenido que ver con mis propias experiencias personales.
Uno podría pensar, leyendo esos libro,
(y me han llegado miles de cartas sobre ellos
de gente que piensa así)
que, basado en la historia de vida de mi padre, como he contado en mis libros,
mi historia temprana de vida, soy alguien que se ha sobrepuesto a la adversidad.
Soy alguien que ha bebido (bebió, bebido)
the los amargos trados de una infancia cuasi desastrosa
y emergió no sólo ileso, sino fortalecido.
Que realmente lo tengo resuelto, así que puedo darle consejo a la gente sobre
la muerte y morir, que puedo hablar sobre el misticismo y el espíritu humano.
Y siempre me he sentido culpable por eso.
Siempre he sentido que de alguna manera era un impostor
porque mis lectore no saben lo que les acabo de contar.
Es sabido por algunas personas en New Haven, obviamente,
pero no es muy conocido.
Así que una de las razones por las que quería venir acá a hablar de esto hoy
es para (francamente, egoístamente)
liberarme de la carga y que se sepa
que no es una mente sin tormentos la que ha escrito todos estos libros.
Pero más importante, pienso,
es el hecho de que una proporción muy importante
de personas en esta audiencia tienen menos de 30
y hay muchos, por supuesto, que tienen mucho más de 30.
Para la gente bajo 30, y me parece que prácticamente todos ustedes
(diría todos ustedes)
están inmersos en una gran y excitante carrera
o justo adentrándose a una gran y excitante carrera.
Cualquier cosa les puede pasar. Las cosas cambian.
Los accidentes ocurren. Algo de la niñez vuelve persiguiéndote.
Y te puede sacar de la pista.
Espero que no le pase a ninguno de ustedes,
pero probablemente le pasará a un pequeño porcentaje.
Para aquellos que no les pase, habrá adversidades.
Si yo, con el espíritu debilitado,
sin espíritu, de hecho, como estaba en los 1970's
y sin posibilidad de recuperación
hasta donde pensó ese grupo de psiquiatras experimentados,
si yo pude encontrar mi camino de vuelta desde eso,
créanme, cualquiera puede
hacerlo de cualquier adversidad que exista en su vida.
Y para aquéllos que son más viejos, que han pasado
algo quizás no tan malo como esto,
pero que han pasado tiempos dificiles
donde, quizás, perdieron todo, como yo,
y empezaron todo de nuevo, algunas de estas cosas pueden parecer familiares.
Hay recuperación.
Hay redención. Y hay resurrección.
Hay temas de resurrección en todas las sociedades que han sido objeto de estudio
y es porque no sólo fantaseamos
con la posibilidad de la resurrección y recuperación,
sino que realmente pasa. Y pasa bastante.
Quizas la temática de resurrección más popular,
,fuera de las específicamente religiosas,
es sobre el fénix, la historia antigua del fénix
quien, cada 500 años, resucita de sus propias cenizas
para vivir un vida que es
incluso más bella que la que habían tenido antes. Richard,
muchas gracias.